23 équipes masculines s'affronter ce
week-end pour la première étape du
championnat de division départementale
de tir à l'arc ces championnats par
équipe sont toujours des épreuves
particulières trois archers doivent
tirer chacun 9 flèches en deux minutes
le temps de tir est donc beaucoup plus
court qu'en individuel il faut réussir à
se synchroniser puisque chacun tire de
flèches donc faut aller vite il y en a
un qui commence à aller tirer les sites
de première flèches ensuite il doit
sortir laisser la place au suivant et
ainsi de suite donc c'est vrai que ça
c'est quelque chose qui faut s'entraîner
puisque bon c'est c'est des automatismes
parce qu'il faut acquérir des
automatismes spécifiques que
l'entraîneur ne peaufine plus le jour J
pour ne pas perturber la mécanique de
tirs
je parle très peu de technique
c'est essentiellement du mental
parce que le tirac c'est quand même
comme tous les sports un peu 80% dans la
tête les archers de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ont remporté
cette première étape du championnat
départemental
Montigny-le-Bretonneux termine au pied
du podium et se classe 4e mais lui en
cours seulement 10e prochaine étape au
tir à 50 mètres le 21 avril